merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre Bruno
Le Maire en matière de politique
économique le gouvernement n'est jamais
avare d'éloges sur ces résultats et vous
venez de nous en donner une illustration
depuis le début de cet après-midi
pourtant nous franchissons un niveau
historique dans des vêtements et nous
sommes déjà les vices champion du monde
des prélèvements obligatoires et des
dépenses publiques et voilà qu'à nouveau
record vient de tomber celui du déficit
commercial qui a doublé en 2022
164 milliards d'euros du jamais vu la
pire performance des pays de l'Union
Européenne dans le même temps
l’allemagne affiche un excédent de 76
milliards d'euros tandis que l'Italie
est en train de renouer avec une balance
commerciale positive bien sûr une grande
part de cette dégradation s'explique par
la hausse des prix de l'énergie du
pétrole du gaz que nous apportons mais
aussi de l'électricité car oui alors que
la France exportait jadis son
électricité nous avons été contraints
dans n'importe quel grand frais tant
vous avez affaibli notre parc nucléaire
et notre souveraineté énergétique mais
tout cela c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt la réalité c'est qu'en fait la
part de la France dans les exportations
mondiales à diminué de moitié de 5 à 2
et demi pour cent la réalité c'est
l'effondrement de notre industrie
manufacturière tombée pour la première
fois sous les 10% du PIB le bilan est
simple en dépit des forts trop
insuffisant sur les impôts de production
votre politique de réindustrie
réindustrialisation pardon ne produit
pas de résultats et nous entreprises
manquent encore de compétitivité
monsieur le ministre votre majorité est
au pouvoir depuis 6 ans et Emmanuel
Macron auparavant secrétaire général
adjoint de l'Elysée puis ministre de
l'Économie et de l'industrie les depuis
11 ans vous ne pouvez pas vous exonérer
de votre responsabilité en reportant
toujours la faute sur les autres alors
allez-vous enfin assumez de défendre
notre souveraineté industrielle pour
permettre à la France d'être compétitive
et à nous entreprises de regagner des
parts de marché à l'étranger